we got the phone guys I also got a few
other red goodies too this is not a part
of that either this is one of my
favorite vlogging tripods it's
incredible not a part of this unboxing
so things are gonna be checking out
today we've got the red Apple watch band
we've got a white case because I kind of
feel like this is gonna look a lot
better than any of the other colored
cases on the red iPhone basically it's
gonna cover up the red I tweeted
something the other day if you buy a red
iPhone and then you put a case on it
will anybody know what you actually have
a red iPhone the Newbery colored leather
case and just the basic red case that
they've had for quite a while and of
course the star of the show I mean you
read iPhone one of the things that I'm
already a big fan of is a silver logo I
don't even mean scissors because they've
got a nice little pull tab here for it
so I did get the 256 I'm not 100% sure
if this is going to be the new phone
that I keep because I really do
absolutely love my jet black phone the
more that I look at it the more that I
am really really into it I also got the
unlocked version also get my phone that
I had previously got we're tied to a
carrier and this is unlocked and when I
travel abroad the best thing ever is
being able to get a t-mobile SIM card
and you'll be able to actually have data
and not worry about any overages
[Music]
moved her up
look at this red I mean this is super
red I am shocked
actually how red it is I mean this is
this is red oh I know what you're saying
yeah no kidding just seen it's red but
look at this this close up and actually
see the true color super red
I don't know what to do what do you guys
think do you think I should keep this
moment or should I stick with my jet
black bone you guys have never taken a
YouTube poll before I've actually never
used it before but I'm going to put one
right now on this video so an annotation
will pop up and you guys can decide do I
keep the phone or do I not keep the
phone as with all iPhones they come with
the USB charging brick you've got your
ear pods and you've got your lightning
cable and of course the infamous dongle
first up the red iPhone case this is not
the new one that just came out this is
the old version I've actually really
wanted a red case for quite a while
because I thought that it would look
incredible
on the black phone which it does I've
seen other people with it and hmm it
looks good and I love this color of red
this is definitely more of a berry Jake
feel like this case will match a little
bit better this is the berry leather
iPhone case here you guys can see the
difference of the colors of red I mean
this is a much brighter red this is more
Nintendo switch red whereas this is I
don't know I guess berry really is the
only other in kind of color I can think
of a more strawberryish color unless you
have some strawberries that are full of
GMOs and this is definitely what you're
gonna be getting I'm not sure if you're
actually gonna be able to tell if
there's a difference but again this is a
much brighter color this is a little bit
more of a darker hue if you don't want
to buy an entirely new phone here's what
you do you buy a case so the longest
time I had a white case on my black
phone and I thought it was
really good so Wow oh my goodness hi
this is gonna drive me crazy like that
looks awful I don't like this look at
all it's essentially like I'm gonna stay
like that
that does not look good look at the
front cool what's this it's like I
spilled a little tiny bit of my jello or
my cherry pudding or some nail polish on
my phone and this doesn't look like it
should be a thing let's open up the
berry case this could be the answer
still the colors are off and if here's
somebody that pays a lot of attention to
detail and small little design things
drive you absolutely crazy I don't know
if there's a good answer for you I'm not
sure what to say so this is the leather
case and this is the silicon case and
you can definitely tell hopefully that
this is much brighter than this one most
of the people who saw that the red
iPhone was announced was basically
saying why didn't they make it an
all-black front I mean this looks really
good red black red white there's just
something about having a completely
flushed screen all-black it looks really
really good and speaking of mismatching
it is black and red like that uh-huh
I'm unsure of what color combination
that you guys would want to do with the
red phone because none of these cases
are aesthetically pleasing moving on to
the readout and watch band this is
actually something that I've wanted to
get for quite a while I have the white
ceramic phone phone hello
a lot of you guys always wonder why I
wear my Apple watch on the wrong hand
and if you're left-handed but this isn't
the wrong hand this is the right hand
and technically it is the right hand now
this looks good so I was able to do this
and rock this with no case on man yeah
this looks great so now I've got a few
questions for you guys
number one I already asked do I keep the
phone do I switch from the jet black to
the red and which case combination did
you guys like the best did you like the
black with the red the white with the
red the red with the red or the leather
berry with the red my favorite phone
color combination
black with the black definitely makes
everything super seamless I also like
the white with the black because what I
do wear my Apple watch with the ceramic
it matches I mean these are all stupid
insignificant details but probably
nobody else in their right mind would
know but you or me and for the red
iPhone let's just say this movie case
looks incredible look at this that
actually matches almost perfectly okay
well now that I look at it through the
camera it's a little bit off but still
you guys get the point thank you guys so
much for watching hope you guys enjoyed
the video and as always I will see you
guys in the next one and make sure you
guys answered those questions in the
comments below and I will see you later
probably tomorrow oh and did I mention
that I was first in line for the iPhone
the red iPhone because there was nobody
else there at 8 a.m. today that's crazy
why would somebody do that what are you
excited about this is big news big news
the bad I phone has actually been
rumored for quite a while and I don't
know if anybody really thought if it was
ever actually gonna happen because
that's what happens with rumors but it's
here yesterday he was